president trump announces his nominee
today to fill the supreme court vacancy
left by the death of justice ruth bader
ginsburg
the president is expected to name amy
coney barrett a federal judge on the
seventh circuit court of appeals
if confirmed barrett will be the third
justice the president has placed on the
supreme court
giving conservatives a clear majority
the nomination comes a little more than
a week after ginsburg's death
on friday her body laid in state at the
u.s capitol
she was the first woman and the first
jewish person to hold that honor
it also comes less than six weeks before
the election which could shift control
of the white house and the senate
back to the democrats the nomination
sets up what could be a fierce
confirmation battle in the senate with
the election looming over the hearings
for more we're joined from washington by
bob cusack he's editor-in-chief of
the hill bob good morning to you you've
already established that the
scotus nomination here will be the
defining issue in this election with the
election
38 days away how important is this for
voters on election day
i don't think it's going to change many
votes but it certainly is going to shore
up the base the base of both the
republican party and the democratic
party because this is such a big deal
this will
really could set the stage on a number
of rulings ranging from
guns to abortion now most people have
already decided who they're going to be
voting for
about 80 percent of the country polls
show but
this is something that i think does help
the president it may endanger some
senate republicans who are in tough
races but this does unify the party and
that's important
for this white house because he has been
at odds with some republicans over the
last
three and a half years senator kamala
harris will be wearing several hats
at this at this hearing as the
democratic
vice presidential pick and as a member
of the judiciary committee so
what are we expecting to see from her
well harris is a former prosecutor
and she did very well on hearings with
uh kavanaugh and also
grilled attorney general bill barr
whether trump was asking him to do any
investigations and barr wasn't really
able to answer
that question he kind of stammered on it
so all eyes will be on harris we haven't
seen much of harris recently she hasn't
done a press conference
uh since she was named so i think this
is going to be a big stage for democrats
have to be a little bit careful not
going too far
and being too aggressive and make a
likely nominee
tony barrett look kind of sympathetic
according to our cbs polling bob trump
and biden neck and neck in big electoral
states like florida and
texas so with less than 40 days to go
before the election how do you expect
both candidates to approach that
well trump is going all out for florida
and absolutely uh trump needs to win
florida if
trump does not win florida uh he's not
going to win a second term so he's been
he's recently gave 8 billion to puerto
rico he recently announced a
prescription
drug plan for seniors that could help
him in florida it's very tight there and
trump also has to win texas he's favored
i think
slightly to win texas but that state has
been changing over the years those are
two basically
must win states uh for the president i
mean biden has to win certain states i
think he's got to win michigan he's
certainly got to win virginia
uh but for for trump uh it's all in for
florida
and bob the trump campaign was focusing
so much on wisconsin speaking of these
swing states and one that he won last
year now it seems like
they're they're focusing a little bit
more on pennsylvania what's the strategy
yeah
well biden has a lead in pennsylvania
but he has not been able to shake
the president uh in between pittsburgh
and philadelphia there there's a strong
trump base there so that is something
that i i think worries the biden
campaign that
that they have not been able to really
expand their lead because that is a
state that usually goes for democrats
but
trump won it in 2016 and that is a
battleground state we also don't know
some of these states including michigan
we may not know for several days after
the election who actually won
the state all right bob cusack my guess
is we'll see you again before the month
is out thanks very much again you can
see the first presidential debate right
here our coverage begins tuesday night
at 9 eastern 8 central on
cbs